images of chaos from the city of Mosul
this video downloaded from social media
sites is set to show Iraqi army trucks
burning in the immediate aftermath of
Tuesday's fighting piles of Iraqi army
uniforms lie abandoned on the roadside
the flight from Mosul continues about
half a million people are said to have
left the city many of them on foot
they're on their way to the Turkish
border in the north all the people have
fled they've left their homes and many
people are lying dead in the streets
will Iraq accept this the situation is
very difficult mortar shells are landing
on the houses we left our relatives
behind and the militants are advancing
Iraqi army patrols came across more
burning debris as the Islamist fighters
moved south west from Mosul through
Kirkuk province in the direction of
Baghdad the Islamists have now taken
over all of Nineveh province and parts
of the provinces of Keokuk and
salaheddine at the beginning of this
year they also captured the city of
Fallujah and large parts of Anbar
province the advance of the militants is
a disaster for the Iraqi government
speaking in Greece the foreign minister
appealed for unity among Iraqi leaders I
hope this incidence really will lead all
of our key leaders to come together to
face this serious mortal threat to the
country Iraqi Prime Minister Nouri
al-maliki has promised a tough response
to the militants and called on leaders
from the country's different groups to
work together that unity has been sorely
missing under al-maliki's Shia Muslim
dominated government Iraq Sunnis have
been left increasingly isolated violence
between the groups has escalated and
that's benefited the militants